es ist für mich eine Freude die deutsche
Bundesaußenminister dürfen
es ist für bearburg der erste Besuch als
Außenministerin zuvor hatten wir bei
verschiedenen Konferenzen die
Möglichkeit gefunden auch in Berlin wir
haben
bilaterale Beziehungen und regional
Themen eine Meinungsaustausch geführt
Deutschland ist ein wichtiger Partner
der Türkei mit strategischer Eigenschaft
multidimensional und wir haben
tiefgreifende Beziehungen wir sind NATO
Verbündete die in Deutschland lebende
türkische Gesellschaft von über 3
Millionen
bindet natürlich die beiden Länder
miteinander deutschland ist der größte
landespartner der Türkei in 2021
erreichte unser handelt Volumen 41
Milliarden Dollar und in diesem Jahr
zeigen die Zahlen dass wir 45 Milliarden
Dollar erreichen können in
2023 haben die Möglichkeit 50 Milliarden
Dollar zu erreichen der Handel des
Volumen ist ein ausgeglichen es gibt
einen kleinen
Defizit aber das kann ausgeglichen
werden aber wir haben einen
ausgeglichenes handelt im Interesse bei
der Länder sind natürlich wollen wir das
Ausbauen und wir müssen in diesem
Zusammenhang weiterarbeiten
das dritte jetcode Treffen
werden während der zweiten Jahreshälfte
Gastgeber sein Wissen dafür bereit in
2021 haben trotz der Einflüsse der
Pandemie über drei Millionen Deutsche
Touristen unser Land besucht und ein
großer Teil in meiner Heimatstadt
Antalya in 2022 kamen die meisten sehen
wir dass die meisten deutschen Touristen
aus Deutschland kommen werden im Thema
Kampf gegen den Terror haben wir
Bedenken zur Sprache gebracht
übermittelt y
ypg und Veto diese Themen haben wir
besprochen es entspricht natürlich dem
verbundeten Geist den Terrororganisation
die Arme zu eröffnen und das möchte ich
hier noch einmal unterstreichen leider
habe ich
die Liste Bernburg übergeben und es ist
eine
Anstieg bei den Aktivitäten der
Terrororganisation PKK zu beobachten mit
verschiedenen Symbolen und Lump
natürlich
außerdem wurde ein Fahrzeug des gegen
rapunzlers in Stuttgart in Brand gesetzt
und wir haben uns Erwartungen an unsere
Hilfe
um dieses Thema verurteilt wir wollen
natürlich konkrete wir haben die
Erwartungen die konkreten Schritte noch
mal möchte ich hier bei dieser Tagung
Frau Berger übermitteln unsere Forderung
habe ich übermittelt
die Einschränkungen in der
Verteidigungsindustrie halten war leider
weiter an und entspricht natürlich nicht
den Verbündeten Geistes haben wir auch
übermittelt und eine Einschränkung unter
den vermündeten sollte es nicht geben
davon gehen wir aus in der kommenden
bevorstehenden Periode wollen wir die
Beratung zwischen den Regierungen und
den
Ministerien wollen wir natürlich wieder
in Takt setzen das ist wichtig wir
wollen alle
Angelegenheiten regionalen lecken halten
und Rahmen dieses Mechanismus können wir
in die Hand nehmen und das sollten wir
auch das wird nützlich sein mit den
Niederlanden haben wir in
wittenbergmechanismus zuletzt hatte hat
eine saugende Ankara stattgefunden die
strategische dialogmechanismus ist heute
wollen wir noch mal wiederbeleben
natürlich
steht auch stehen auf dem
Verhandlungstisch wir wollen die
politischen Hürden wir wollen die
Aufhebung dieser erhöhten die
sollte konkrete Schritte bedeutende
Schritte setzen
die wir wollen die
Wiederbelebung der Zoll
der Union und natürlich wie die Visa
Freiheit ist eine
Beförderung von uns in
2016 in der gemeinsamen
migrationserklärung wo wurde da in
diesem Platz eingerannt besonders
als zwei Länder in Europa wollen wir die
Zusammenarbeit
ausbauen im Thema in der Ukraine
die Arbeiten die Schritte die wir
gesetzt haben und über die Entwicklungen
habe ich Informationen an Frau bärburg
übermittelt denn unsere Zusammenarbeit
ist für die Lösung der Probleme in der
Region kann natürlich zu einem kann
natürlich dieses Thema in Bewegung
setzen
in regionalen Themen sollten wir die
Zusammenarbeit ausbauen aber bei dem
heutigen Gespräch haben wir den Ukraine
Krieg die Getreideexport und auch einen
Meinungsaustausch über den Krieg geführt
das getreideabkommen zuvor hatten wir
auch ein schriftlich eine Information
übermittelt an Werbung
als Türkei haben wir sowohl mit der
Ukrainer als auch mit Russland Kontakte
dieses wir wollen natürlich zur
Fahrzeugen des politischen Engagements
und dass die Probleme auf dem
Verhandlungstisch auf dem auf dem
Fahrersicht gelöst werden dass diese
Firma müssen wir Brote Bedeutung bei im
Zusammenhang des getreide-exports das
getreideabkommen in Istanbul wollen wir
ihn bevorstehenden Prozess
vertrauensbildende Schritte setzen und
das das natürlich auch zu einer
waffenuhr führt auch wenn es
unterschiedliche Themen sind und dass
das ohne Probleme fortgeführt wird ich
hoffe dass das zu einer positiven
Atmosphäre führen wird natürlich dass
dieses Abkommen erfolgreich fortgesetzt
wird dass das umgesetzt wird ist die
Türkei bereit alle ihren Verantwortung
nachzukommen sie hatte gesagt dass wir
auch das Zentrum für das Getreide das
getreidezentrum besuchen sollten aber
das können wir dem nächsten nachholen
wir haben in den regionalthemen EU NATO
Syrien all diese Themen und und wir
haben eine in Tehran eine masdona Format
ein die Tagung veranstaltet ich habe
Frau bärbock informiert deutschland hat
im Thema östliches Mittelmeer die wir
wollen dass Deutschland diesjährig
ausgeglichene Haltung fortsetzt dort
anschließend Deutschland das Drittländer
das Provokationen und propaganten
besonders die propagandas vor und der
südzypischen Administration dass sie
nicht zu einem Instrument von Südzypern
wird Deutschland hat in der
Vergangenheit Denise Prozess eine
aufrichtige Vermittlerrolle übernommen
eine ausgeglichen Haltung dargestellt
dargelegt aber in jüngster Zeit
sehen wir dass dies Ausgeglichenheit
leider verloren gegangen ist
wir müssen beide Seiten uns anhören wir
müssen uns Information von beiden Seiten
sammeln und ohne Vorurteile die sehen
Informationen
nimmt wir dürfen nur eine Seite weil sie
nur EU-Mitglied ist und weil die Türkei
keine EU Mitglied ist dass die Türkei
nicht aufrichtig ist deshalb sollte man
diese Provokationen nicht
nachkommen wir sind bereit alle Themen
am Verhandlungstisch zu besprechen dass
diese Probleme durch Frieden durch
Dialog gelöst werden können genauso wie
der Krieg in Ukraine
auf diplomatischen Wege gelöst werden
sollte
der Rassismus und Islamfeindlichkeit in
ist in Europa da sind wir besorgt wir
als Mission haben einen Bericht
vorbereitet denn es ist wirklich ein
ernster Anstieg zu beobachten besonders
in der pandemiezeit gegenüber Muslimen
gegenüber Moscheen sind ernste
Anschläge zu beobachten besonders die
muslimische Gesellschaft die Sicherheit
und die Bedrohung also das sollte
erwarten dass hier Maßnahmen getroffen
werden wir sind hier bereit in Deutsch
mit Deutschland zusammen zu arbeiten
gegen jegliche Diskriminierung gegen
jede Art von Rassismus müssen wir
eigentlich gemeinsam vorgehen sehr
geehrte Frau Berger ist eine natürlich
eine aufmerksame Politiker ich habe mich
bei ihr bedankt zum Beispiel wurde für
die NSU türkischen NSU in Nürnberg wurde
ein Denkmal eröffnet und hat dort bei
der Eröffnung eine Botschaft gegeben und
habe möchte mich bei ihr für dieses
Sensibilität bei ihr bedanken mit diesen
Gefühlen möchte ich Sie nochmals hier
begrüßen und übergebe Ihnen das Wort
bitte sehr
schlecht herzlichen Dank danke
lieber mehr wird für den späten Empfang
bei meinem Antrittsbesuch danke dass wir
das auch aufgrund meiner
corona-krankheit relativ spontan jetzt
noch mal nachholen können und das an
einem Freitagabend ich weiß diese Geste
der Gastfreundschaft wirklich zu
schätzen und dann noch mit so einem
wunderschönen Ausblick aufs Wasser
heraus das unterstreichte wie wichtig
auch bei manchmal Wellengang ein gutes
Miteinander ist dass wir gemeinsam
weiter segeln können wir hatten heute
ein sehr offenes und ehrliches Gespräch
und ich glaube das ist auch unser beider
Art dass man nicht um den heißen Brei
herumredet sondern dass man gerade bei
Themen wo man unterschiedlicher Meinung
ist auch ein offenes Wort findet bei
Plattitüden auszutauschen ist jedenfalls
aus meiner Sicht keine
verantwortungsvolle Außenpolitik und wir
sind eben nicht nur außenpolitikes und
außenpolitisch unterwegs sondern vor
allen Dingen im Namen
eigenen Bürgerinnen und Bürger deswegen
ist die Beziehung zwischen unseren
beiden Ländern so wahnsinnig wichtig und
deswegen ist es für mich so wichtig dass
wir uns gegenseitig im Respekt begegnen
gerade auch wenn man unterschiedlicher
Meinung ist denn deutsch-türkische
Beziehungen sind wirklich etwas
Besonderes in so vielen Menschen in
unseren beiden Ländern schlägt ein Herz
für unsere beide Länder wir haben dafür
eine gemeinsame Verantwortung und wir
müssen deswegen unsere Beziehung pflegen
und das ist nicht nur eine menschliche
Frage sondern es ist ein riesiges
Potenzial das wir ausschöpfen sollten
zwischen menschlichen Beziehungen
zwischenmenschlichen Kontakten Familien
und Freundschaften aber gerade auch im
wirtschaftlichen Bereich es gibt viele
Bereiche gerade jetzt auch mit Blick auf
die Klimakrise der Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien mit Blick auf
Abhängigkeiten von Energien
energiepartnerschaften in die wir weiter
gemeinsam investieren können denn unser
gemeinsamer Energiehunger ist groß und
deswegen ist es ein guter Schritt das
möchte ich an dieser Stelle auch sagen
dass die Türkei jetzt auch das Pariser
Klimaabkommen ratifiziert hat weil das
auch die Grundlage für uns ist für
zukünftige wirtschaftliche und vor allen
Dingen energiepolitische Projekte um
Potenziale auszuschöpfen ist
gegenseitiges Verständnis nötig es setzt
nicht nur klare Botschaften voraus
sondern vor allen Dingen auch ein
offenes Ohr deshalb werde ich meinen
Besuch auch verlängern und heute Abend
noch nach Ankara fliegen ich werde mich
dort auch mit geflüchteten aus Syrien
und aus dem Irak Treffen an dieser
Stelle gilt über all die Jahre hinweg
und weiterhin unser großer Dank an die
Türkei dass so viele Menschen hier
Zuflucht gefunden haben vor Brutalität
Bomben und vor Terror
Menschlichkeit darf keine Abstriche
haben und die Aufnahmebereitschaft hier
im Lande untermauert das eindrucksvoll
wichtig ist deswegen auch für mich als
deutsche Außenministerin als Mitglied
der Europäischen Union dass wir weiter
sicherstellen dass vier Millionen
geflüchtete aus Syrien in der Türkei in
Würde und Sicherheit leben können und
dass wir das weiterhin auch finanziell
von der Europäischen Union und zwar
verlässlich unterstützen
ich will an dieser Stelle auch gleich
offen sagen auch das Völkerrecht hat den
Schutz des und der einzelnen im Blick
die Folge von militärischem Handeln ist
fast immer Not und Leid und das Recht
auf Selbstverteidigung gilt für alle
aber das Völkerrecht setzt ihm eben auch
zu recht enge Grenzen dazu zählt das zum
Recht auf Selbstverteidigung weder
Vergeltung noch abstrakte
Präventivangriffe zählen und das gilt
aus Sicht der deutschen Bundesregierung
eben auch für Nordsyrien das Leid der
syrerinnen und Syrer würde durch eine
erneute militärische Auseinandersetzung
noch einmal schlimmer werden und
zugleich sehen wir neue Instabilität
dort nützt nur Terrororganisationen wie
dem is die wieder Fuß fassen können und
ja
der Minister hat das gerade noch mal
sehr sehr deutlich unterstrichen in
unserem vier-augengespräch aber jetzt
auch in der Pressekonferenz mir ist mehr
als bewusst uns ist mehr als bewusst die
Türkinnen und Türken haben ein echtes
Bedürfnis und ein Recht auf Sicherheit
so wie jeder es andere Land auch wir
wissen dass die Türkei tatsächlich durch
Terror bedroht wird eben auch durch die
PKK eigentlich ist das eine
Selbstverständlichkeit weil seit Jahren
bereits für die gesamte Europäische
Union gilt aber da das hier eben noch
mal so angesprochen wurde und ich nicht
möchte dass irgendwelche
Missverständnisse im Raum bleiben auch
im nachklub dieses Besuches möchte ich
noch einmal unterstreichen die
Europäische Union und dazu zählt
natürlich auch die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland hat die PKK als
Terrororganisation gelistet und sie wird
auch so in Deutschland behandelt und da
eben ein paar Einzelfälle angesprochen
worden sind ich meine die Stärke eines
Rechtsstaates ist ja
jede Straftat verfolgt wird wenn Autos
angezündet werden egal aus welchem Motiv
wird das verfolgt wenn ein
terroristisches Motiv dahinter steckt
wird das strafrechtlich zusätzlich mit
diesen Straftatbestand verfolgt und
natürlich handhabt jeder Rechtsstaat das
entsprechend und natürlich auch mein
Land
unser Hauptthema ist an dieser Stelle
aber natürlich der brutale russische
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine gewesen
das hat der Herr Minister bereits
deutlich gemacht
dass dieser Krieg mit den brutalsten
Mitteln geführt wird mitten in Europa
mit einem kompletten Bruch auch des
humanitären Völkerrechts wo Zivilisten
bombardiert werden und zwar nicht nur
aus Versehen daran trägt allein Russland
Schuld wir dürfen uns nichts vormachen
da sind wir uns sehr einig und
Außenminister lavrov hat das ja noch mal
öffentlich ausgesprochen russland will
die Ukraine unterwerfen
Millionen Menschen werden gnadenlos aus
ihrem Heimat aus ihren Häusern aus ihrem
Zuhause vertrieben und wer bleibt das
sehen wir in den Belagerten Regionen der
ist nicht sicher auch wenn die Bomben
nicht mehr fallen sondern er riskiert
sein eigenen Tod wir sind uns daher sehr
einig dass wir das nicht hinnehmen
unsere Botschaft ist klar das haben wir
auch beim Nato-Gipfel gemeinsam noch mal
unterstrichen wir werden die Ukraine
weiter unterstützen solange wie nötig
Freiheit und Selbstbestimmung können
eben nicht nachverhandelt gekappt oder
relativiert werden
die Türkei ist mit der Ukraine sehr eng
verbunden und die türkische
Unterstützung gerade auch mit der
Lieferung von Drohnen zu Beginn dieses
Krieges war ein sehr sehr wichtiger
Schritt und hat der Ukraine vom ersten
Moment angeholfen heute oder morgen soll
jetzt zum ersten Mal seit über fünf
Monaten ein Schiff mit ukrainischen
Getreide dem Hafen von Odessa verlassen
unsere beiden Botschafter Botschaften
sind zusammen gemeinsam vor Ort und an
dieser Stelle herzlichen Dank für das
Engagement der Türkei in dieser
Situation das war wirklich ein großer
Schritt der da erreichte worden ist
wir müssen sehen wie das jetzt
tagtäglich wirklich funktioniert in der
Praxis wir haben auch die direkte
Bombardierung danach auf Odessa gesehen
aber dieses Abkommen das was hier auch
erreicht wurden ist gerade von ihrer
Regierung ist ein Schimmer der Hoffnung
für Millionen Menschen weltweit die von
Hunger bedroht sind
dafür unser herzlicher Dank und Respekt
die Türkei liefert durch Sicherheit im
Schwarzen Meer auch darüber hinaus einen
extrem wichtigen Beitrag auch hier zeigt
sich erneut wie wichtig es ist dass wir
gerade in dieser so schwierigen
Situation als Nato-Partner
zusammenhalten dazu gehört ich habe das
bereits gesagt dass wir unter Partnern
auch in diesem Verteidigungsbündnis
unsere Differenzen im Dialog lösen denn
gerade jetzt spielt ein Streit nur den
in die Hände die uns Spalten wollen
das habe ich auch bereits heute in Athen
gesagt wichtig ist es deswegen dass wir
Spannungen abbauen und nicht verschärfen
und weil sie ja Minister das gerade
angesprochen haben auch mit Zypern wir
sind als Europäische Union eben auf
einem Fundament gebaut dass wir keine
Binnengrenzen mehr haben weil wir eine
gemeinsame europäische Außengrenze haben
und deswegen ist eben das Thema dieser
gemeinsamen Außengrenze auch unser aller
Thema
was Gespräche für Sicherheit im
östlichen Mittelmeer leisten können das
wird aus meiner Ansicht niemals mit
Eskalation zu erreichen sein vielleicht
für einen Moment ganz kurzfristig aber
niemals mittel und langfristig und
unsere Politik ist ja nicht für das
gestern gebaut sondern für die Zukunft
unserer Kinder und Enkelkinder gerade
als Partner in einem Bündnis ist es
daher aus meiner Sicht eine
Selbstverständlichkeit dass wir unsere
Grenzen gegenseitig respektieren
deshalb ist es mir ein so wichtiges
Anliegen dass wir nicht politisch
auseinanderdriften in diesen Moment denn
unser größtes Kapital das sagte ich zu
beginnt sind die Menschen in unseren
Ländern
lebendige Zivilgesellschaft ist Zellkern
unserer Beziehung im Inneren wie nach
außen und auch da hatten sie gerade eine
einzelne Fälle angesprochen mit Blick
auf Rassismus auch hier sind wir auf dem
gleichen Fundament gebaut und das
Fundament ist der Europarat aus den
schlimmsten Taten die mein Land begangen
hat wurde dieses gemeinsame europäische
Haus auf der Europäischen
Menschenrechtskonvention aufgebaut da
sind Kernbestandteile ebend Recht auf
Asyl freie Meinungsäußerung aber eben
auch der Kampf gegen Rassismus der Kampf
gegen Antisemitismus der Kampf gegen
Gewalt aufgrund von religiöser Herkunft
und auch da möchte ich hier noch einmal
unterstreichen damit es keine
Missverständnisse gibt natürlich gilt
das für jede Religion in eurem Land
genauso wie in meinem Land und wir haben
gerade als neue deutsche Bundesregierung
deswegen mit Blick auf Antisemitismus
anti-isl und auch mit Blick auf
Rassismus unsere Strukturen nochmal nach
verschärft sei es mit Blick auf
Sicherheitsbehörden zum Beispiel für
unabhängige polizeibeauftragte sei es
durch die Benennung der
Antidiskriminierungsstelle mit einer
Person die genau dafür steht und sei es
auch im Alltag ich glaube das ist eine
Aufgabe für uns alle und ein gemeinsames
Vermächtnis unser Großeltern damit
lebendige Gesellschaft entsteht braucht
es nämlich eben Teilhabe und Teilhabe
braucht Rechte für jeden einzelnen
Menschen und dafür trägt der Staat
Verantwortung
dafür müssen wir als staatliche Akteure
als gewählte Regierungen als
Volksvertreter tagtäglich sorgen und
kein Land ist 100% perfekt ansonsten
würde man nicht in einer freien
Gesellschaft leben aber unsere Aufgabe
ist dazu dafür zu sorgen wenn Unrecht
gescheht dass jeder zu seinem Recht auch
kommt und dafür das sage ich auch an
unsere eigene Adresse müssen wir jeden
Tag aufs Neue sorgen damit dass jeder zu
seinem Recht kommt gerade in Fällen wenn
Unrecht gesteht haben wir uns Pflichten
gegeben die verankert sind im Europarat
die Europäische Menschenrechtskonvention
hat dafür vor über 70 Jahren ein Anker
gesetzt dass Menschen in Essen wie in
Erzurum sich darauf berufen können jeden
Tag und das ist unsere politische
Aufgabe auch 70 Jahre später
dazu zählt für mich auch dass unsere
Bürger gegen staatliches Unrecht ein
Mittel in der Hand haben den Gang zum
Europäischen Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte als eine Generation gut
40 Jahre alt hatte ich das große Glück
ein Leben lang in Demokratie und
Freiheit in meinem Land leben zu können
im westlichen Teil und deswegen ist es
für mich eben auch als Außenministerin
eine Verpflichtung
egmr-urteile zu achten und zu
verteidigen und zwar ausnahmslos und zu
jeder Zeit dazu gehört für mich auch die
vom Europäischen Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte angeordnete Freilassung
von Osman Kavala
mir ist bewusst dass es in diesen Zeiten
schwierig ist über Themen zu reden wo
wir auch in so einer Pressekonferenz
beide vielleicht zucken aber wie gesagt
ich glaube es sind keine Zeiten wo man
nicht ein offenes Ort findet sondern es
sind jetzt genau Zeiten wo man auch
bereit ist sich gegenseitig zuzuhören
auch wenn einem vielleicht die
Ohrenschmerzen mir ist bewusst für ein
Freundschaftsbesuch haben wir Tele
Themen angesprochen wo wir
unterschiedlicher Meinungen sind aber
gerade weil für mich die Freundschaft
zwischen unseren beiden Ländern und vor
allen Dingen zwischen unseren Millionen
Menschen so wichtig ist kann
Freundschaft eben nicht heißen
Plattitüden auszutauschen und sich dann
hinterher hinter dem Rücken des anderen
über die wahren Argumente noch mal
nachzubesprechen Respekt von Angesicht
zu angesichts das ist das was solche
Termine ausmachen daher herzlichen Dank
dass wir heute hier zusammenkommen
konnten und auch viele Fragen die nicht
ganz oben auf Titelseiten stehen viele
Fragen die in praktisch keine große
Rolle spielen dass die heute Abend auch
im Anschluss noch Platz haben dazu
gehört für mich auch die Lage in Libyen
die auch für die Türkei ein wichtiges
Thema für die regionale Sicherheit ist
Deutschland hat mit der Berliner
libyenkonferenz mit dem Berliner Prozess
versucht einen wenn auch sehr sehr
mühsamen so ist die Realität
internationalen Konsens herzustellen und
ich begrüße sehr dass die Türkei sich
hieran weiter beteiligt denn die Lage
die neuen Auseinandersetzungen und toten
machen uns beiden glaube ich ähnlich
große Sorgen
lieber Herr Minister lieber mehr Glück
ich danke sehr für das heutige Gespräch
was wir gleich nach der Pressekonferenz
noch fortsetzen werden nichts kann wie
gesagt den persönlichen Austausch
wirklich ersetzen und ich freue mich
sehr wenn Du demnächst auch nach Berlin
kommen kannst auch wenn ich leider sagen
muss dass der Blick von dem Presse Puls
in Berlin eine ganz ganz anderer ist man
blickt nämlich auf Trödel und triste
Übersetzer Kabinen aber an der Stelle
auch herzlichen Dank an die Übersetzung
danke schön
meine Frage ist an die Ministerin
Staatspräsident Erdogan während seiner
Kontakte in Teheran gibt es ein Foto sie
haben eine Kommentare abgeben und es
wurde von der
Medien wieder spielen sie haben das als
Herausforderung kommentiert was wollten
sie damit meinen Eltern Putin und und
auf demselben mit und Herren Ciao solo
die Frage die ich selber Frage gilt auch
an sich was würden Sie dazu sagen
Gespräche in diesen wahnsinnig
schwierigen Zeiten sind mehr als wichtig
und das ist auch unsere Stärke im
nato-bündnis dass wir nicht sagen alle
reden genau exakt mit den gleichen
Leuten sondern dass wir in unseren
unterschiedlichen Rollen auch
unterschiedliche Themen und
Herausforderungen wahrnehmen und
deswegen habe ich eben auch noch mal so
deutlich unterstrichen die Rolle die die
Türkei gespielt hat dabei dass das
getreideabkommen zustande gekommen ist
die hätten vielleicht nicht so viele
andere Länder an dieser Stelle gemeinsam
mit den Vereinten Nationen übernehmen
können und es war ja keine
Selbstverständlichkeit dass die
Vereinten Nationen auch mit am Tisch
sind sondern genau dieser Punkt wurde
von den Russen ja immer wieder
hinterfragt und dass das jetzt im Rahmen
gemeinsam mit den Vereinten Nationen ist
das ist aus meiner Sicht auch eben der
Beitrag der türkischen Regierung gewesen
deswegen ist natürlich
selbstverständlich dass wenn man über
solche Abkommen spricht man auch im
gegenseitigen Gespräch auch mit dem
russischen Präsidenten sein muss der
dieses Abkommen ja am Ende dem zustimmen
musste
zugleich wissen wir alle wie stark die
Macht von Bildern ist und dass dieser
Krieg eben Hybrid geführt wird er wird
nicht nur mit Bomben geführt er wird
nicht nur mit einer Blockade von
Getreide geführt sondern er wird auch
mit Bildern und Propaganda im sozialen
Netz geführt und daher habe ich
angemerkt dass für mich persönlich aber
es ist eine persönliche Auffassung das
für mich eben diese Symbole nicht zu
unterschätzen sind und das gilt auch mit
Blick auf dieses Foto
vielen Dank für diese Frage aber bevor
ich zu dieser Frage über gehe möchte ich
zu einige cm Ende zu den Kommentaren
möchte ich auch meine Gedanken ja zur
Sprache bringen zum Beispiel in Syrien
als Türkei haben gegen ein paar
parteiisch PKK ypg haben wir einen
führen wir kriegen wir haben viele
Soldaten gefallen heute
gestellt PKG mir Drohung für die Türkei
da zuletzt im letzten Monaten wurden
vielen 25-deutsche Soldaten ist vieles
Zivilisten sind gestorben viele
Zivilisten sind getötet worden wir
erwarten von unserem Verbündeten
das ist kein militärischer
Auseinandersetzung einen
Auseinandersetzung zwischen den
armenfall der Staaten statt das ist ein
eine Operation gegen Terroristen und wir
werden sie wir wenn sie sagen dass sie
Fahrzeuge verstehen wir wollen das nicht
wirklich dass Sie auch unsere gerechte
Forderungen ja auch unterstützen
wir wenn sie mit gegen Deutschland
kämpfen wollen dann kommt sie ausfällt
und kämpfen gegen da ich und dann
säubern Sie da ich vom Feld von den
Fremden Kämpfern ypg BKK die bekämpfen
nicht die da ist im wie Sie wissen wie
sie
waren in afghansdorf zusammen
das internationale Recht ist sehr
wichtig
im Rahmen des internationalen die
Landesgrenzen auch die EU-Grenzen wenn
man die Grenzen schützt muss man auch
das internationale Recht berücksichtigen
die pushbacks von Griechenland dass sie
jetzt
dass sie in den Tod gesetzt werden dass
sie entkleidet werden das bedeutet nicht
der Schutz der Grenzen und aus diesem
Grund die Verstöße von Griechenland zu
ignorieren
internationalen Rechts und ist nicht
humanitär kommen wir zum internationalen
strafgerichtsinn des parlamentischen
erst am blies wir haben
Werte die wir verteidigen
aber es gibt kein verantwortungsloses
Land natürlich sagt
die Kommentare von Bärbel über Kavala
ist es ist ihre eigenen Ansicht kann sie
auch zur Sprache bringen sie bekommt
Frau wer bekommt aus Griechenland und
wird vor der Presse
die Beschlüsse die nicht wenn Sie daran
erinnert hätten Griechenland dass die
Beschlüsse des europäischen
Strafgerichtshofs nicht berücksichtigt
werden
denn die Beschlüsse gegenüber der
türkischen Minderheit in Griechenland
werden nicht umgesetzt in Frankreich
gibt es Beschlüsse gleichzeitig
werden diese Bachelor seit 2011 seit elf
Jahren werden diese Beschlüsse nicht
umgesetzt zum Beispiel das hat mit
Folter zu tun kommen wir zu Norwegen
auch ein ist kein EU-Mitglied aber ein
Mitglied des Europarates im Thema
soziale Rechte von Kindern Frauenrechte
wenn es mir immer Bedeutung aber der
europäische Strafgericht so die
Beschlüsse werden nicht umgesetzt kommen
wir zu Deutschland
in Deutschland wie Sie wissen
Deutschland Klage da gibt es einen
Beschluss des Strafgerichts in
Deutschland
unhumane
Vorgehensweise und wir in welchem Jahr
wurde das verurteilt vor sechs Jahren
sehr
bös sagt wenn sie sagte dass die
geschlichen Beschlüsse des europäischen
Strafgerichtshof nicht umgesetzt werden
da würde ich sie respektieren aber das
eigentlich gilt auch in anderen Ländern
warum wenn das in anderen vielen Ländern
so der Fall ist
wie wenn jeder türkische Bürger werden
alle inneren Rechtswege ausgeschöpft
sind gilt gelten auch andere Wege das
gilt auch für Osman Kavala und auch
andere Bürger der Europäische
Menschenrechtsgerichtshof
hat die Türkei die Freilassung aber er
wird in anderen Themen angeklagt und
durch die verschiedenen klagen wurde er
bestraft verurteilt
das ist nicht nur der europäische
Strafgesetz auch das Verfassungsgericht
innerhalb dieser
Hierarchie kann er sich an verschiedene
Gerichte zuwenden man muss die
Beschlüsse der Gerichte
respektieren aber der europäische
menschengerechtshof wenn die inneren
Rechtswege nicht ausgeschöpft wegen im
Rahmen wenn wenn Sie das istanbulant
kommen nicht ausgeschöpft wenn das in
diesem Rahmen
bewertet ist das eine politische
Entscheidung wenn so viele mischurteile
Beschlüsse nicht umgesetzt werden wenn
man Griechenland daran nicht erinnert
wird warum wird immer Osman kavaland die
tagsordnung gebracht denn denn sie
benutzen aus meinen Kavala gegenüber die
Türkei aus gehen bei den Gizeh wir
wissen wie er finanziell unterstützt
wird wie sie ihn unterstützt haben daher
wir halten sie aus man kann immer an der
Tagesordnung und der Europarat bei mir
nicht weiter ministerrattag und auch bei
den Abstimmungen rufen Sie alle Länder
an
und einige Länder haben auch gesagt dass
Deutschland diese Länder droht und und
warum werden diese Länder
warum wird diese Bemühung gegeben es
gibt auch andere Gerichtsbeschlüsse ich
habe alle Beschlüsse gegeben Beispiele
gegeben ich kann auch andere bevor
gegeben aber bevor wir eine Doppelmoral
hier geben sollten wir uns
zusammensetzen und darüber sprechen was
wir im Rahmen des rechtsunternehmen
können wir sind immer bereit diese über
diese Themen zu sprechen wenn ich hier
zu jeder Frage komme es gibt eine
einfache Antwort natürlich sollte man
das im Rahmen der diplomatischen
im Zusammenhang mit dem Treffen ich habe
das auch
verurteilt dass dass sich das Foto nach
dem Treffen von Erdogan mit Putin
dass die Hürde wir ich hatte erwartet
dass das hier die das getreideabkommen
unterstreicht werden sollte
wie kann man denn sonst diese Probleme
nicht lösen die Augen sind auf die
Türkei gerichtet denn es gibt im Thema
Waffen nur viele Hoffnungen von der
Türkei
wir haben uns nie behauptet dass wir
alles lösen aber wir geben uns große
Mühe sowohl mit selensky als auch mit
Russlands sind auch wenn wir nicht in
Dialog mit diesen beiden Ländern wie
sollen wir diese Bemühungen fortsetzen
wie können wir dieses Thema ausgeglichen
fortsetzen und die Staats- und wir sind
auch der bemüht die Staats- und
Regierungschef wieder zusammenzubringen
im Namen der Menschheit im Rahmen der
bilateralen Beziehung im Rahmen der
regionalen Angelegenheiten
letzten Endes dass wir
zusammenkommen ist auch nützlich für
Syrien
kann die internationalen Gruppe zu sich
Zusammentreffen
was ist mit den Mechanismus die in
derselben meinungsstündlich kann auch
schriftliche Informationen geben aber
die Informationen sind ihnen allen vor
aber wir können auch in diese
Informationen zur Verfügung stellen
durch das erst deiner Format sprechen
über das
in der UN gibt es kein kein Prozess der
funktioniert wir dürfen auch Syrien
nicht vergessen hier gibt es einen
Bürgerkrieg und hier sterben seit elf
Jahren die Menschen sie haben auch ihre
Sensibilität in diesem Thema zur Sprache
gemacht vielen Dank aber wenn wir in
diesen Format zusammenkommen ist für uns
Region sehr wichtig und das sollte man
natürlich
respektieren und das sollten wir nicht
an ein Foto jetzt hängen bleiben und das
finde ich nicht richtig wenn ich sage
das auf die planerische Weise diese
Länder die über die Gespräche zwischen
den Ländern dass man diese kommentiert
natürlich gibt es eine meinungsfrei aber
die Diplomatie hat natürlich auch ihre
eigenen Regeln daher hat jeder jeder
kann mit jedem sprechen und muss
natürlich kein anweisen von einem
anderen sich zu holen
vielen dank Michael Fischer deutsche
Presse Frau Ministerin baerbock sie
haben sich sehr deutlich zu Nordsyrien
geäußert nach dem letzten türkischen
Einmarsch in Nordsyrien 2019 hat die
damalige Bundesregierung einen
teilweisen
rüstungsexportstopp verhängt danach
dürfen keine oder sollen keine deutschen
Waffen mehr nach Syrien in die Türkei
exportiert werden die in Syrien
eingesetzt werden könnten führt diese
Bundesregierung diesen
rüstungsexportstopp fort und können sie
sich weitere Sanktionen vorstellen wenn
es wie angekündigt zu einer weiteren zu
einem weiteren zu einer weiteren
Offensive in Nordthüringen kommen wird
und zum Thema Rüstungsexporte würde ich
auch gerne noch wissen ob die
Kooperation beim Bau von U-Booten
fortgesetzt wird trotz heftiger Kritik
heute auch wieder seitens Griechenland
Herr ministerschaft olo Ministerin
baerbock hat sich heute morgen in Athen
sehr stark
positioniert in der also in dem Streit
um die griechischen Inseln in der
östlichen Ägäis hat sich klar auf die
Seite Griechenlands gestellt ich würde
gerne wissen ob Sie Verständnis dafür
haben dass die EU-Partner an dieser
Stelle zusammenhalten oder ob sie das
als Affront sehen und die angekündigten
Erdgas Erkundungen wann und wo genau
werden die stattfinden werden da auch
wieder umstrittene Gebiete betroffen
sein
relativ viele Fragen in einer also ich
nehme mal die raus die hat mich
gerichtet waren und hoffe keinen
Teil davon nicht zu berücksichtigen also
mit Blick auf die Rüstungsexporte auch
das ist ja Grundlage von Rechtsstaaten
dass man Dinge vollzieht die man vorher
gesetzlich oder in Verordnung und
Vereinbarungen geregelt haben wir haben
klare Regeln zu unseren Rüstungsexporten
nämlich mit Blick auf Nato-Partner und
EU-Partner und strenge Beschränkungen
für Drittstaaten und zugleich gilt auch
für alle NATO und EU-Partner dass das
was für uns im Inland gilt mit Blick auf
den Einsatz von Gewalt dass das
natürlich auch mit Blick auf alle
anderen Partnern gilt und die
Leitplanken bilden da das Völkerrecht
aber wir erleben ja auch hier
wahrscheinlich auch auf die Frage die
gleich von meinem türkischen Kollegen
beantwortet wird mit Blick auf das
Seerecht auch dass das Völkerrecht an
manchen Stellen interpretationsfähig ist
und dass wir offensichtlich an manchen
Stellen unterschiedliche
Interpretationen haben unsere mit Blick
auf die Rüstungsexporte auf der
vergangenen Bundesregierung dass mit
Blick auf die Gefahr dass wenn
Rüstungsgüter zum
Menschenrechtsverletzungen mit
eingesetzt werden können oder mit Blick
auf Dinge die wir als völkerrechtswidrig
sehen dass wir dann entsprechende
Maßnahmen und Schritte ergreifen die hat
die letzte Bundesregierung ergriffen und
mit Blick auf die Themen die wir heute
angesprochen haben wird ja glaube ich
deutlich dass wir viele Fragen haben wie
die wir gerade in diesem Bereich des
Völkerrechts auch weiter gemeinsam
diskutieren müssen weil wir
unterschiedliche Auffassung haben ich
habe ja gerade mit Blick auf Nord Syrien
unterstrichen und das gilt für mich
gerade in diesen Monaten wo wir
international deutlich machen wir
verteidigen hier auch das internationale
Recht dass wir natürlich das
internationale Recht an jeder Stelle
verteidigen und daher gerade meine
Ausführung auch zu Nordsyrien die sie ja
gehört haben in diesem Zusammenhang ohne
dass wir jetzt hier in ein ständiges Hin
und Her mit Blick auf das Völkerrecht
einsteigen möchte ich nicht desto trotz
anführen weil das eben Nord Syrien und
Nordirak auch mit betrifft dass die
Genfer Konventionen ja nicht nur
geschrieben worden sind zwischen
Konflikten zwischen Staaten sondern sie
umfassen auch nicht staatliche Akteure
sie binden alle Akteure die militärische
Gewalt anwenden deswegen haben wir auch
vier Genfer Konventionen und dass
deswegen die Einhaltung des humanitären
Völkerrechts gerade auch für Situationen
gilt die nicht die klassischen
zwischenstaatlichen Kriege sind und dass
das Gebot der Verhältnismäßigkeit in
allen Fällen gilt bei der
Selbstverteidigung in jeder anderen
Situation um Zivilisten dafür wurden ja
die Genfer Konvention unter anderem auch
geschaffen in diesen furchtbaren
Kriegssituationen überhaupt bestmöglich
schützen zu können
ja vielen Dank
der Schutz von Zivilisten und Menschen
und die Flüchtlinge in der Ägäis das
Leben der Menschen ist auch äußerst
wichtig das Thema Inseln haben sich
schon ein Kommentar abgegeben ein
Kommentar gemacht
das Deutschland parteichhandelt das
haben das Körper das an der Seite von
Griechenland ist aber in strategischen
Themen
zu glauben und Partei zu ergreifen das
erwarten wir nicht von Deutschland wir
haben Deutschland immer gewürdigt wir
haben mir meine Vermittlerrolle erwartet
mit Griechenland haben mehr
Streitigkeiten in der gesunde mit mir
aber die Türkei ist natürlich für eine
friedliche Lösung mit mit
Gesprächen
mit annäherungsgesprächen haben wir das
mit Griechenland fortgeführt im März hat
Staatspräsident mit mitzutage ist hat er
in Istanbul bei einem Mittagessen
empfangen das war ein schönes Gespräch
mit mir zu Tages aber Griechenland hat
mit einer
schwarzkampagne eine Lobby geführt aber
dabei
wird das aber nicht im Rahmen des
internationalen Rechts geführt und wenn
das nicht so ist dann dann sollte man
diese Propaganda nicht gehört schenken
das ist der Brief an die UNO ist sehr
offen und klar
und wovon besteht ein Beschlusses ein
Internationalen Gerichtshof von es gibt
Verträge es gibt beströße und natürlich
gibt es auch internationale Abkommen wo
Länder Parteien
ergreifen im Lausanne 1923 und 1927 und
47 mit dem Friedensabkommen von nossa
wurde ein Status aber es gibt auch für
einige eine Legenden Ausnahmen in diese
können nicht aufgerüstet werden um diese
Insel werden auch aufgerüstet und wenn
wir von internationalen Rechts
besprechen wenn es dann wenn
Griechenland Fehler begeht dann sollte
man das auch zur Sprache bringen
wir haben das in diesem Brief den
Vereinten Nationen zur Spar gemacht wir
haben hier gesagt dass Griechenland
gegen diese international Verträge
verstößt und die Antwort von
Griechenland entspricht nicht dem
Intension Recht und Kriegen an Brot und
macht Propaganda kann intern dann seid
ihr im Rahmen des internen rechts keine
Antwort gegeben
sie sollten auch in der Leistung
Griechenland sagen können das
Griechenland Unrecht ist aber Jugend
geht zu sein bedeutet dass man hier im
für jedes irgendwie ein recht hat und
Menschenrechtsverstöße und jede Art von
Fehler
Missbrauch
heißt
das wird intern gehalten und ja in jedem
Lager wird das unterstützt intern als EU
ist sowohl auch die wichtigen Länder als
ein wichtiges Land der EU sollten wir
sprechen was wir unternehmen werden
könnte Merkel Frau Merkel hat das so
gemacht damals hat Deutsch hat war
Deutschland ein aufrichtiger Vermittler
war ausgeglichen deutsche über Politik
war ausgeglichen aber so war das
entschuldigen sie werden das auch
respektiert wir sagen nicht dass sie uns
auf unsere Partei ergreifen sollten wir
erwarten von
und Gerechtigkeit aber Griechenland auch
immer und die Rechner sagt immer auch
wenn ich im Unterricht den unterstützen
mich aber und da wirklich dann auch ein
erfolgreicher aber so sind die Julian
aber Deutschland sollte hier hatte
Deutschland eine ausgeglichen und
vertraute vertraute Position und wir
wollen dass Deutschland diese Position
fortsetzen und das erwarten wir von
Deutschland wenn ein Land in Unrecht ist
und dass das Unrecht ist was man
trotzdem dieses Land unterstützt das bei
mir leider nicht
[Musik]
angesprochen vielleicht können Sie auch
etwas hinzufügen Sie sind aus
Griechenland hierher gekommen besonders
bei dieser Pressekonferenz haben die
über pushbacks in der Ägäis
äh Oles
vor über frontext in dem jüngsten
Bericht wurde von der Spiegel
veröffentlicht frontext diese
unrechtlichen pushbacks das wurde vor
allem nicht das hat sich herausgestellt
am 7 Juli
und der Internationale Strafgerichtshof
hatte natürlich nur verurteilt
internationalen Recht wird spricht die
spricht sie auf damit die nationalen
Recht warum
ignorieren sie drücken Sie bei Thema
Griechenland bei denen Andreas Verstößen
ein Auge zu und kam dieses Thema beim
Gesprächen auf die Tagesordnung
ich hoffe sehr dass mit Blick auf unsere
gegenseitigen Austausch an manchen
Stellen die Übersetzung vielleicht nicht
ganz sauber ist mit Blick auf Argumente
die man hier austauscht dass das
natürlich keine Propaganda ist wenn man
unterschiedliche Sichtweisen ist sondern
dass man offensichtlich eine andere
rechts oder politische Auffassung an
dieser Stelle hat und vielleicht auch
auf ihre Frage noch mal mit Blick auf
die Pressekonferenz ich glaube das ist
eine politische Stärke ist dass man da
sagt wo Dinge im eigenen Land oder auch
in der Europäischen Union und
deutschland ist eines der größten Länder
der Europäischen Union deswegen kümmere
ich mich dual care about the external
borders of my European und daher habe
ich auch in Griechenland sehr sehr
deutlich angesprochen weil genau in dem
Tag der Olaf Bericht veröffentlicht
wurde von der antikorruptionsstelle das
mit Blick auf das was dort dargestellt
wird und wir wissen manches ja auch aus
Berichten die bereits vorher
veröffentlicht worden sind das ist
offensichtlich Fälle gegeben hat wo
illegale pushbacks gegeben hat ich
möchte nur an dieser Stelle darum werben
es ist immer einfach große Schlagworte
gegenseitig sich und dem Kopf zu hauen
dass man sehr stark differenziert wir
haben eine europäische Außengrenze eine
Außengrenze muss gesichert werden so wie
das jedes Land tut macht das auch die
Europäische Union und auf Wasser ist das
sehr sehr schwierig das heißt das
Agieren von einer Grenzschutzagentur
europäisch Frontex oder auch den
griechischen Grenzschützern das ist eine
Selbstverständlichkeit an der
europäischen Außengrenze dort wo es
allerdings zu Menschenrechtsverletzungen
gekommen ist müssen diese aufgeklärt
werden das habe ich gestern in Athen
gesagt das sage ich heute hier in
Istanbul das habe ich vor einigen Wochen
in Berlin gesagt als es die ersten
Berichte darüber gegeben hat und ich
glaube niemanden bricht ein Zacken aus
der Krone weil es gibt keine perfekte
Welt festzustellen dass wenn Unrecht
passiert ist dass das aufgeklärt werden
muss und dass das angesprochen werden
muss und das gilt für mich egal ob es
sich um griechischen Grenzschutz um
europäischen Sonnenschutz handelt oder
um türkischen Grenzschutz wir haben eine
gemeinsame Europäische
Menschenrechtskonvention und den
Europäischen Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte haben ja immer den
Strafgerichtshof in der Übersetzung aber
in Europäischen Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte auf denen ich mich an
dieser Stelle beziehe und natürlich
setzen wir die entsprechenden Urteile
alle gemeinsam um und ja manchmal dauert
das länger weil kein Land perfektes aber
ich glaube das fingerpointing der eine
hat vor zehn Jahren nicht das getan und
das ist das Argument für heute
jedenfalls ist das nicht meine Art von
Politik und Sie können sich gewiss sein
dass es in unserem ureigenen Interesse
ist das an der europäischen Außengrenze
die europäischen Werte auf denen die
Europäische Union gebaut ist verteidigt
werden weil wenn wir da wegschauen dann
gehen unsere europäischen Werte im
Mittelmeer unter
vielen Dank
wenn es ein Fehler gibt möchte ich
korrigieren ich sage nicht dass frau
Berger eine kommen eine Propaganda führt
dass sie zu einem dass die von Reglern
geführt Propaganda dass sie diese
Probleme als richtig annehmen
das sollte man keine unausgeglichene
Politik führen man sollte dir das
Gleichgewicht wahren Griechenland für
diese Propaganda Griechenland ist hier
ist sehr erfolgreich auch ist Service
macht nutzt das sehr gut aus macht für
diese Probleme sehr gut und diese
Propaganda man sollte beide Seiten beide
Parteien sich anhören und in diesem
Rahmen
sowohl Land als auch internationale
Organisationen man sollte gerecht und
ausgeglichen Handeln natürlich führen
sie kein propagandas haben wollte ich
nicht sagen dass wir auch nicht richtig
das ist die pushbacks habe ich ja meine
Meinung schon gesagt aber das möchte ich
nicht wiederholen aber Griechenland das
von das was Griechenland ist nicht ohne
ist inakzeptabel dass die Boote aus
gestorben die Luft herausgenommen wird
dass die Menschen zum Tod verlassen wird
19 Flüchtlinge sind
gestorben die pushbacks und die
Europäische Union die Institutionen
sowohl des Parlament als auch der
Urlaubsbericht hat wurde das
festgestellt ich hoffe die können hier
aufrichtige Ermittlungen durchgeführt
werden
migrationsthema ist ein internationales
Problem
und das wird auch anhalten wegen
verschiedenen Gründen das sieht man in
das sollte man im internationalen Recht
in die Hand genommen werden aber
Menschen aber man sollte natürlich im
Menschenrechte hier berücksichtigen
würden sie das akzeptabel finden wenn
eine türkische Firma an beide
Kriegsparteien Waffen liefert und zwei
Fragen an Ministerin Werbung finden Sie
das akzeptabel wenn Russland von einer
NATO Mitgliedstaat Waffen bekommt und
der zweite Frage an Ministerin was tut
die Bundesregierung für die Freilassung
von Osman Kavala und Salat damit das
vielen Dank
das was sie schon gesagt haben als
Türkei ist keine offizielle Erklärung so
was haben wir habe ich nicht gesagt das
haben sie gesagt das wurde in den Medien
so behauptet bisher wurde kein Gespräch
eine Bemühung gibt es leider nicht aber
wenn wir
es ist doch nicht richtig über die
Medienberichte zu sprechen
wir haben von Russland das S400 du
verdankungssystem gekauft auch in einer
Zeit wo wir es dringend brauchten haben
wir keine luftverteilungssystem erwerben
können besonders an der syrischen Grenze
haben viele Verbündete einschließlich
Deutschland ihre patchworksysteme aus
der Türkei abgezogen auf verschiedenen
Gründen die wir beschuldigen sie auch
nicht nur spanien hat die Patsche System
in der Türkei gehalten vor einigen bis
vor Jahren haben wir das Soundsystem in
der Türkei benutzt und wir waren
gezwungen dass es 400 Systeme zu kaufen
von sondern es gibt viele Einwände
zwischen beiden die
es ist ein Thema der Zuwendung Recht ist
zwischen beiden Ländern ich sage wir
sagen dass bei jedem Gelegenheit aber
aber mit Russland steht eine Drohne das
Thema Drohne nicht so Debatte das was
sie sagen behauptet haben wird nicht von
der türkischen Republik hergestellt wird
einer von einer privaten Firma
erfolgreich hergestellt und verkauft bei
der Stadt die Drohnen die
bestücken und das jetzt kommen auch die
arkanische Drohnen die werden von
verschiedenen Ländern beantragt aber
zwischen den Staaten gibt es keine
Gespräche und die Firma
wenn die Firma einen Antrag erhält wie
stellt sie projektions und wir
übermitteln uns Ansichten vielen Dank
gemacht dass es eine hypothetische Frage
ist und auch hypothetische Fragen gibt
es glaube ich da nichts weiter zu sagen
deswegen müssen sie mir noch mal den
zweiten Teil Ihrer Frage an mich
wiederholen
[Musik]
ja
auch bei den beiden Fällen habe ich
jetzt glaube ich ausführlich deutlich
gemacht was unsere Haltung ist auch mit
Blick auf die konkreten Fälle den
Europäischen Gerichtshof und unsere
Verständnis der Menschenrechtskonvention
und dazu habe ich nichts mehr
hinzuzufügen
soweit also die Pressekonferenz von
Außenministerin berworg gemeinsam mit
ihrem türkischen ans Amtskollegen Carolo
in Istanbul das war also eine sehr
ausführliche Erläuterung der beiden
Positionen es gab ganz unterschiedliche
Politikfelder die angesprochen worden
sind es gab Gemeinsamkeiten die
unterstrichen worden sind aber es gab
auch sehr viel Dissens bei den
unterschiedlichsten Bereichen Josef
Janning der Politikwissenschaftler hat
sich das hier gemeinsam mit mir
angeschaut was würden Sie da jetzt raus
destillieren aus dieser sogenannten
Antritts aus diesem sogenannten
Antrittsbesuch von Frau bärbock in der
Türkei es gab ja zum Beispiel zum
Stichwort Propaganda ordentlich Klartext
oder ja
man hat deutlich gesehen dass Annalena
baerbock nicht bereit ist
Differenzen zu beschweigen man konnte
sogar den Eindruck gewinnen dass sie ein
Teil dieser Positionierung dazu nutzt um
ein bisschen Druck auf die türkische
Seite zu machen die ja nicht auf Appelle
reagiert sondern die im Prinzip nur auf
Druck reagiert und das vielleicht auch
diese Position die sie in Athen so
bemerkenswert geäußert hat in Bezug auf
die Inseln Teil einer solchen
Positionierung gegenüber der Türkei ist
man hat auf der anderen Seite in der
türkischen Reaktion gesehen sozusagen
das was die Türken besonders umtreibt
das ist aus ihrer Sicht diese
Doppelmoral diese doppelzünigkeit der
EU-Politik und auch der deutschen
Politik deswegen dieser ja doch
unverhohlen vorgetragene Wunsch
Aufforderung an Deutschland nicht Partei
zu ergreifen den bärbock ja ebenso offen
abgelegt hat abgelehnt hat und
gleichzeitig auch dieses